Tariq Owens come in New York to eat at a
Jewish deli with Simpson left [ __ ]
they when I heard there was a guy in the
NFL Sims named Tariq : yeah I said Wow
Khayyam we've got ourselves and finally
a Jewish running back and then I found
out not only have you never been to a
Bar Mitzvah not only have you never had
Jewish food you're not Jewish
sadly no sadly I appreciate the side
Cohen though I mean that's in the Mount
Rushmore of Jewishness
it really is I am a hundred percent
Jewish yeah what I want to give to you
is the full Jewish experience I can call
it a Jewish combine to making you feel
like a true Jewish man are you ready to
take this journey with me oh yeah I'm
definitely ready
[Music]
this is our first dish this is a
customary Jewish breakfast do you want
to take a guess as to what is in front
of you right now sushi sushi
it is not sushi smoked salmon jeez if
this exactly man yes man is right all
right so don't be afraid of it
no I'm not so why don't you pick it up
oh that was a oh my god hold on don't
like it you don't do you mind if I have
a bite you have all the mice okay I mean
it's perfect this is a Jewish deli
staple and it's not just what it is
this is a pastrami on rye and do you see
how much meat is on there yeah excessive
okay Miffy he looked at that like it was
a blitzing linebacker when it came in he
like literally looked at it it was like
why don't you bite into that sorry on
the foots worth hmm and this is part of
the process to the strategy of how to
bite the eye I could see that I'm going
to try to flatten him nice I think he's
gonna like this do they already
confident about it I really give you
credit for having the guts to just dive
in there though quads goat cheese and
nothing only no cheese mayonnaise or
something well that wouldn't be kosher
we have one more this is the Cadillac of
Jewish food tarik Cohen I'd like to
introduce you to your new favorite food
matzo ball soup matzo ball matzo ball
have you heard of matzo balls before
mozzarella mozzarella not the same this
is not cheese there's no cheese in there
there's no cheese you thought matzo
balls had cheese - I totally did so the
best way to do this is to take your
spoon take a little piece of the matzo
ball get a little bit of soup in there
oh it though it's very soft and there it
is oh good that's the test my chicken
noodle soup really it's chicken noodle
soup
the second part of our Jewish combine is
Jewish slang no not only do I want you
to eat like a Jew I want you to talk
like a Jew so here's the first word this
is gonna be fun
it is smooth schmooze what do you think
smooth means good sleep good sleep Oh
like I should marry those two moves i'ma
go smooth so if smooth is actually to
like kind of talk somebody up hey I like
your play calls mad [ __ ] that's a real
bit of all unusual move oh you suppose
you win right next word whoo good luck
saying this one shoots bah quit spa
quits
all right [ __ ] together how we were in
the team meeting and Tariq Cohen stood
up and said I don't like that play
Tariq's got a lot of hutzpah like mouth
yeah exactly
this is the Jewish slang phrase of all
generations we've a boy Vey what do you
think it is tarik Cohen was supposed to
run the slant route and he ran the
go-round
boy 8 to recon or it's like all those
pickles for me
Jose oh yeah guys you thought both is
the good air man it could be everything
yeah that's the one I may use right
there you have ace the Jewish combine
and I have a gift for you Oh baby we've
a I give you a Chicago Bears yarmulke
Jewish Vidia a Jewish fitted cap yes oh
my gosh it looks so beautiful you're not
out of here oh I like it
put that bad boy on yeah and I have an
Eagles yarmulke now we celebrate let's
give it up for
[Applause]